I have decided in 2020 to run for
president yeah well not anymore
a source tells ET kanye west is ending
his 20/20 campaign for president of the
united states just 11 days after
announcing his run on twitter ET source
explained quote although kanye does have
political aspirations one day he
realizes a lot more goes into it than
just saying his plans you think the
source added that the rapper is gonna
think things through a little further
next time telling ET quote kanye and his
family have decided that if he does
pursue politics in the future that he's
prepared and has everything in order to
make a legitimate run i feel like i have
a responsibility according to New York
Magazine's Intelligencer a member of
Kanye's campaign team Steve Cramer
confirmed that the 43 year old rapper is
no longer planning on going up against
President Donald Trump and Democratic
nominee Joe Biden in this year's
election simply put Steve said quote
he's out and also added running for
president has to be one of the hardest
things for someone to actually
contemplate at that level any candidate
running for president for the first time
goes through these hiccups et has
reached out to Kanye's reps for comment
Kanye announced his intention to run on
the 4th of July tweeting hashtag 2020
vision and discussed his campaign in an
interview with Forte's saying he was
running as a member of the birthday
party and said he no longer supports
Trump he also named a Wyoming preacher
Michelle Ted ball as his pick her VP
Kanye even filed paperwork with the
Federal Election Commission which is a
necessary step to getting on the ballot
as for Kanye's famous family a source
recently told et they had concerns over
his presidential aspirations mainly that
he tends to overwork himself and doesn't
take time to rest but we do know through
thick and thin wife Kim Kardashian
stands by her man's side I've seen him
go through a lot and he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that might get misinterpreted and
people don't see the context behind it
but I always know his heart
[Music]